these divers
are on a mission
park clean up part rescue
the area they're working in is in the
gulf of thailand
and this is their target the thousands
of
tons of old fishing nets dubbed ghost
nets
littering the ocean every year ghost
are actually really dangerous because
once they are
fallen into the ocean they can stay
afloat for decades
so either marine animal will be
entrapped there
or they will digest those nets and then
that would lead to
health problems that eventually lead
them to die
discarded fishing gear is one of the
deadliest forms of ocean
plastic pollution harming 66 percent of
marine mammal
species
once the ghost nets are spotted the
divers have to measure and log them
trapped animals alive or dead are also
recorded
the nets are then carefully cut free and
collected
while some are tangled deep below the
surface
others are much easier to find
this is a huge problem we've swam about
10 minutes and we've already found our
first
net and around 50 000 small fishermen
carry these alone in thailand the amount
that are littering
the ocean floor is still unknown
the collected nets are returned to the
boat bag after bag
they keep mounting up
what we can see is a variety of pieces
of net and rope
and obviously a single fairly sizable
battery
back on the land the nets are separated
and cleaned
unwitting catches inspected
so what we can see here is clearly a
dead individual there's no animal left
inside
so it has been entangled in the net and
been unable to escape
i've just spotted another one also dead
once clean the nets are given a new life
shredded
and reprocessed some have been turned
into
cove advisors 47 fishing communities in
thailand are helping with the cleanup
getting paid for the nets they salvage
but the challenge is huge we have the
band-aid solution at the beginning which
is to actively remove the nets
that deals with the symptom it prevents
further things from getting entangled
the finally the source of the problem is
another matter entirely
discovering the source first requires
understanding the scale of the problem
so campaigners and scientists will
meticulously log
every ghost net they spot in the hope
they can find a way to
finally read the sea of this deadly
rubbish
siobhan robbins sky news thailand